For the past decade or more, the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has dominated box the box office
and pop culture as a whole.
But sandwiched in between the MCU mega-blockbusters
Captain Marvel and Avengers: Endgame, there's
another little superhero movie from the underdogs
at DC Comics, and it's actually really awesome.
How awesome?
Well, here’s a spoiler-filled look at the
four best and four worst things about Shazam!
The films of the DC Extended Universe have
a well-earned reputation for being dark, grim,
and gritty, which a lot of audiences felt
weren't too much fun to watch.
There’s a lot of angst and moral ambivalence
and very little in the way of actual heroism.
Instead, they seem to feature angry people
who clearly aren’t getting enough fiber
in their diets.
So maybe the biggest surprise about Shazam!
is that it’s not just funny, it’s also
actually fun from start to finish.
Director David F. Sandberg mostly does a great
job keeping the tone upbeat and energetic
as teen Billy Batson discovers his incredible
new powers.
It’s true that Aquaman also dared to have
at least a good time along the way, but Billy’s
exuberance at becoming a superhero is something
we haven’t really seen before, and is a
welcome change compared to the DCEU’s usual
dark and violent fare.
"Did you believe?"
"...yeah!"
On the other hand… while Shazam! is mostly
family friendly fun, once in awhile it just
sort of forgets itself and veers off into
the realm of horror.
Of course, this makes some sense considering
that Sandberg is best known for directing
the acclaimed horror hits Lights Out and Annabelle:
Creation.
Still, the tonal shifts are jarring.
One minute, Billy and his foster brother Freddy
Freeman are clowning around doing the floss,
and then the next minute, the evil Dr. Sivana
is summoning a horde of demons to literally
eat people’s heads off.
"Oh, snap!
You're like a bad guy, right?"
These abrupt detours into terror feel kind
of out of place and unnecessary.
Luckily, it doesn’t happen often, but even
a couple of times might be a couple of times
too many.
Across the board, the stars of Shazam! deliver
and then some.
Zachary Levi, as the superheroic adult form
that young Billy takes, maintains a level
of boyish wonder while using his grown-up
physicality to great comedic effect.
He also has terrific rapport with Jack Dylan
Grazer as Billy’s foster brother Freddy
Freeman.
And Grazer similarly has excellent chemistry
with Asher Angel, who plays the younger, less-mighty
mortal version of Billy.
It’s hard enough for most movies to find
even one star that’s right for any given
part.
But Shazam! somehow nailed the casting for
its three biggest roles, and the movie is
much better for it.
Still, not every role comes off as well as
it could have, and one area where the movie
really falls short is its villains.
That’s not actually a knock on actor Mark
Strong, who plays the lead villain, Dr. Thaddeus
Sivana.
Strong has a long history of playing baddies
in films, and he’s very good at being very
bad.
But unfortunately, while all the stuff with
Billy and Freddy feels fresh and new, the
scenes with Dr. Sivana feel like they were
cobbled together from a list of boring super
villain cliches.
Plus, his demonic CGI helpers have boring
designs.
The coolest thing Shazam! did with villains
was teasing Mr. Mind, an evil genius worm,
in the mid-credits scene.
We just wish he had been the lead villain
of this one too.
At least that wouldn’t have been just more
of the same.
When moviemakers don’t respect the comics
their films are based on, the result is always
bad, and always disappointing.
Just look at films like Jonah Hex, or even
Man of Steel, which was controversial among
longtime comic book fans.
In that one, many have said that director
Zack Snyder didn’t believe the concept of
a pure hero like Superman was relevant.
The impulse to make comic book movies "more
serious" because the filmmakers want to be
taken seriously is never a good thing.
Which is why it’s so great that Shazam!
actually revels in its comic book origins.
The filmmakers don’t mind being goofy, because
they know it's fine as long as audiences are
brought along for the ride.
Characters like Mr. Mind are silly but they're
exactly the kind of silly we’ve been waiting
for all along.
Shazam!
Is trying to do a lot of different things.
It’s got comedy, it’s got action, it’s
got a heart-warming family message at its
gooey center, and it’s a modern superhero
fable.
But while it does most of those things pretty
well, trying to do them all at once results
is a movie-going experience that's kind of
like trying to eat a Chipotle burrito: it’s
just overstuffed.
And that over-ambition shows in the film’s
run time.
For a fast-paced, fun movie, Shazam! isn’t
actually all that fast-paced.
Instead, it runs a whopping 2 hours and 12
minutes, which is maybe a half hour too long.
Shazam! is really good, but like the old saying
goes, sometimes you can get too much of a
good thing.
A little restraint would have been better
for the movie… and better for your bladder.
"Superpowers?
Dude, I don't even know how to PEE in this
thing!"
Like all good films, Shazam! is actually about
something more than simple superhero fist
fights.
At the heart of the film is young Billy Batson
and his quest to find his family.
In the end, he realizes his true family was
right in front of him all along.
It’s a great arc, made all the better by
the performances of the actors who play his
foster siblings, especially Faith Herman as
the precocious Darla.
Even better, the twist ending where all his
siblings are granted the powers of the wizard
Shazam is a great callback to the comics.
Seeing Billy and his siblings come together
to fight crime was a great surprise that delivered
both the action and the feels at the same
time.
About the only thing that could have made
the superhero family twist even better was
if we hadn’t already known it was coming.
So who spoiled it for everyone?
No, it wasn’t some paparazzi or gossip website.
Instead, it’s the modern scourge of film
fans everywhere: merchandise tie-ins.
Yes, unfortunately images of the action figures
were leaked months before the film’s April
release, spoiling the surprise.
Hey, toy companies, next time could you please
keep it zipped until after the movie is out?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.